hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast finding coherence in
chaos by embracing evolution and
complexity it is presented by Kenneth
beautto PhD director of the
computational Sciences and informatics
program for complex adaptive systems and
professor in the School of Life Sciences
at Arizona State University I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be our
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before I begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Bhutto I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you very much my name
is Kim Bhutto from Arizona State
University I want to begin by indicating
that I have no disclosures relevant to
this particular presentation and move
into essentially what's the fundamental
research question that this presentation
is attempting to ask and answer and
that's what drives common disease
etiology and outcome I'm a lifelong
geneticist in genomics as not this has
been a question that has motivated my
research career since the various early
inception
we all know and from our own personal
experience that different people with
different circumstances respond
differently to environmental exposures
and that not and that risk for common
disease is not uniformly distributed
among the population shown on this slide
we can see a cartoonish example of that
where we know that some people when they
smoke go on to have morbid outcomes such
as heart disease and/or lung cancer but
on the other hand we also are aware that
others seem to be able to have
particular environmental exposures with
impunity and have no ill health or
morbid consequences a brand new field in
in biomedicine has emerged to try to
attempt to address this concept and
that's captured under the concern of
personalized or precision medicine as
this audience is aware of personalized
or precision medicine is about
delivering to the right individual the
right care at the right time and the
right place and in personalized medicine
we recognize that the cancer community
has been one of the fundamental pioneers
in this space now interestingly given my
historic background at the National
Cancer Institute and as a lifelong
cancer investigator I would like to
believe that this is actually
attributable to her our insightfulness
in the cancer community in fact an
arguably nothing could be further from
the truth one of the reasons that the
cancer community was an early adopter of
personalized and precision medicine was
the recognition that unfortunately many
of our drugs as shown at the bottom of
this slide just were completely
ineffective we knew that some
individuals responded but we didn't know
when or why or who so the cancer
community was a very early adopter of
the definition the molecular definitions
of medicine and as a consequence was one
of the very early poster children this
is a magazine from almost 20 years ago
now at this point this
describing how we were using targeted
therapeutics based on the molecular
basis of disease to try to advance the
field of cancer therapeutics and
understanding of cancers cancer
susceptibility unfortunately as an early
adopter being on the bleeding edge of
personalized medicine we actually
discovered early on that unfortunately
the simple approach of where we would
find a mutation in a particular tumor
and develop therapeutics to attack that
particular mutation is shown on this
particular slide while having benefit
and you can see merely an immediate
benefit in terms of survival what we can
see is at the end of the day
unfortunately many of these therapeutics
have been disappointing and then in fact
the reason they're disappointing is that
within weeks in this instance we can see
the mean difference here is as few as 12
weeks difference 12 to 14 weeks
difference in overall survival with the
treatment of this specific targeted
therapeutic that addressed a particular
single mutation in cancer and as a
consequence of that that the overall
efficacy of personalized and precision
medicine has been overall questionable
in terms of changing the outlook of
cancer so why is that the case
well we actually know it's the case now
with further characterization of cancer
in its examination that cancer when we
look at it is not a simple disease but
in fact is quite complicated and I'll
get to in a moment quite complex we now
know that when we look at cancers across
individuals we can see that there are
literally hundreds of alterations in
these cancer cells and that these
hundreds of alterations are working in
combination with each other to produce
the cancer phenotype we've learned that
these cancer mutational profiles are due
first among different individuals so
even though there's hundreds of
individual cancer mutations what we see
is that very rarely do we see an only in
a small percentage do these cancer
mutations overlap with one another
more pragmatically what we see is that
within a cancer the cancer itself is not
homogeneous with respect to these
hundreds of mutations that in fact the
cancer tumor itself is a hodgepodge of
many many different cell types as shown
in the bottom right portion of this of
this figure we can see it given to or
actually is composed of essentially many
many different types of cells with many
different types of mutations and these
different mutations then have the
capacity to change over time and in
response to the individual therapeutic
intervention so when we have these
exquisitely targeted mono therapies we
do a great job of knocking out one type
of these cells but then very rapidly the
remaining cells respond and extra
compromised the outcome and health of
the individual this finding is actually
generating some significant controversy
in the community and some actually
exasperation probably best captured by
one of the pioneers of molecular
oncology Robert Weinberg at the
Whitehead Institute at MIT who actually
has in some sense thrown up his hands
and suggest that cancer is just too
complicated and that our current
understanding renders cancer almost
unapproachable well I would actually
argue and again as a student of
complexity and as a member of the
complex adaptive systems group here at
ASU that actually this complexity is not
unanticipated as what we now know from
the molecular mechanisms and in fact
just requires us to look at the problem
in a different way and I'll use a
metaphor of the point lists the flavor
of impressionist painters at the turn of
the 20th century
the pointillist shown here is a segment
of a pointillist painting and what you
can see here is the collection of
individual dots that actually underpin a
given painting and what we can see here
is not unlike the circumstance we find
ourselves in in the cancer community
right now we now have the ability to
characterize in exquisite detail the
molecular characterization of every
tumor but what we see now is a
disconnected collection of points
especially when we're looking at from
this reductionist point of view that our
care is what we care about is the
individual points but instead if we
actually pull back and begin to look at
how the points interact with each other
and how in combination and in context
the points produce a hole that's more
than the sum of their parts produce an
emergent property we can see that this
what appears the chaotic pattern starts
to a chaotic randomness starts to emerge
into a pattern so if we pull back a
little bit we can see that these
individual dots come back to actually
form a particular shape and form and if
we look at how these combinations of
dots in this particular figure interact
with other figures we can begin to see
the overall emerging story of how this
particular collection of dots or
mechanisms or our components then
interact into a much larger story and we
can see that what was confusing and or
uninterpretable at the individual dot
level when we look at the integration of
these individual dots and how the
collections of dots interplay with other
sets of collections of dots we can begin
to understand the whole story to do this
then requires us to approach our
phenotypes are complex phenotypes or are
our common phenotypes as complex systems
so we take a minute or so to define what
is a complex system or a complex system
differs from a simple reductionist view
of the world by the fact that we care
about the relationships the
interconnectedness and the evolution of
that system the system itself learn and
adapt in response to the conditions now
think back to what we saw with respect
to this exquisitely targeted mono
therapy targeted therapy and we could
see that the cancer as a complex system
adapt to this but I think two key home
taken two key take-home lessons emerges
first a complex system cannot be
understand simply by taking apart and
analyzing the individual components
having or knowing the individual genes
independent of their context does not
help us or does not is not the answer to
the problem knowing the individual
components is an important first step
but we have to see how they work with
respect to each other and that's because
what we see in complex systems is a
phenomenon known as emergence where
combinations of things produce an
outcome that's different than the
individual effects and those
combinations simply stated one plus one
can equal zero instead of two or one
plus one
maiik hwal three and because of that
what we see is that you can't simply fix
a complex system by manipulating a
single component you have to alter its
trajectory and I think the best metaphor
for this is shared on the the my
favorite Google Doodle forma that
represents an Alexander called our
mobile and those of you if I've ever
seen one of these Mobile's in in action
what you can see is touching any
individual piece of this sets the entire
sculpture in motion and it's very
difficult to predict how the action of
any one specific leaf of this sculpture
will result in its overall movement and
we might argue that in complex systems
we need to know both all of the pieces
and how they're interconnected so
how does this change our thinking about
looking at common disease in common and
common complex traits well first if
you're going to approach a complex
adaptive system one of the things we
have to do is admit that this is in fact
a complex system this is surprisingly
hard to do in the biomedical community
that's been trained for now generations
to use reductionist approaches that the
presumption that if we just find the
gene for this or the gene for that that
we will have actually cured cancer or
diabetes or obesity or multiple
sclerosis the idea that there's a single
driving individual factor so first and
foremost we have to change our global
thinking but it's not once we do that
then there are some very specific steps
as to how we can start to embrace
complex adaptive systems and have an
impact on these on these large phenomena
in biomedicine so approaching first step
is the good news is that we're well
along the way in this and in terms of
our current paradigms is that we have to
inventory the components we've now done
a great job we now can routinely get
genomes and see how all those pieces and
an inventory all of the pieces and their
individual states but what we're not as
good at yet is actually understanding
how those pieces come together and one
of our critical components then in
approaching complex systems is not only
finding what the pieces are but
conducting the experiments that allow us
to see how they interact with one
another another novel feature though of
complex systems is recognizing that it's
dynamic now when I say dynamic that
means and as we saw from our cancer
treatment example is that it changes
over time it changes in response to its
environment it changes in response to
intervention so if we want to actually
understand complex systems we have to
measure them not at a single point in
time but look at their trajectory how
they change over time and more
importantly not only how they change
over time but how do they change with
perturbation or with under different
sets of environmental or therapeutic
conditions lastly and again something
that's been done for a long time in
biomedicine but we have lost somewhat is
we have to model the system now I'm a
geneticist by training and and my choice
and what we recognize is that actually
this is something that's been lost in
the field of life sciences in
biomedicine in general while we're
familiar with model systems like
Drosophila or mouse model systems in
biomedicine we failed to recognize that
actually much of our fundamental
understandings and in the life sciences
has emerged from modeling systems
arguably friar Mendel as a geneticist
was one of the first modelers in the
sense that he was looking for ratios
when he was studying his pea plants
again another model system of
inheritance to try to under under
understand and identify what were the
models of his time ratios 1 - 2 - 1 - 2
- 1 9 - 3 - 3 2 1 all of these different
Mendelian ratios that we all commiserate
you know that we all suffered with them
and we were taking our undergrad
genetics courses so we've made progress
in cancer as shown here is this slide of
where we stand with respect to cancer
arguably our reduction or leveling of
the incidence cancer has been in spite
of our efforts to develop therapeutics
as I showed on the earlier slides
largely probably attributable to changes
in lifestyle reduction in smoking
reduction in other key exposures that
may perhaps and have cancer
increasing so the general rule for
cancer today as we can see is either
flat incidence or slightly decreasing
incidence which is positive news however
this is not the case for all cancers and
what we see is that in fact there are a
number of cancers a small number of
cancers that draw
matically violate this premise and i'm
going to focus a little bit on one of
these specific types of cancer because
this is what i'm going to drive the rest
of my presentation around our
investigation of this other form of
cancer or one of the forms of cancer
that isn't following this pattern that
would be a pada cellular carcinoma
so hepatocellular carcinoma is the fifth
most common cause of cancer in incidence
and the second leading cause of cancer
mortality hepatocellular carcinoma is
the most common form of liver cancer and
in fact has a dismal five-year survival
less than 18 percent five-year survival
but more problematically is what we can
see is over the last two decades the
incidence last two to three decades the
incidence of hepatocellular carcinoma
primary liver cancer has doubled in the
United States there's a number from the
seer registry in the United States and
we can see that in all races white black
Asian Pacific American Pacific Islanders
in each of these different groups the
incidence of liver cancer has increased
interestingly this is not just an
American phenomena but in fact a
worldwide phenomena and in the abscess
in the instance of eastern Asia where
there have been efforts put to
eliminating one of the primary risk
factors of primary liver cancer we can
see worldwide I apologize difficult to
read in this but suffice it to say that
any region of the world that you look at
shows an increasing rate of liver cancer
similar to what we're seeing in the
United States so just to focus you with
a red box we can see here in North
America the trend I showed you on the
previous slide but we can see even in
places as distant as India we can see
that the rate of liver cancer in the
last two to three decades has nearly
doubled so this is a cause for pause is
liver cancer likely to be for
our generation and our children's
generation what lung cancer was to our
generation and our parents generation as
you all are probably aware prior to the
onset of the 20th century lung cancer
was a very rare disease and it was only
with the widespread distribution of
smoking brought on by the world wars and
other lifestyle changes driven by by
marketing and and tobacco firms we saw
an explosion of lung cancer is this
trend we're seeing in liver cancer going
to be the same as what we saw in lung
cancer if that's the case what is it
that's driving this change in liver
cancer well historically liver cancer
had three primary causes of its etiology
hepatitis C hepatitis B and alcohol and
you can see both of these are still
tremendously high risk factors and if
one has a chronic infection for
hepatitis C or hepatitis B one has
astronomically high rates of developing
liver cancer however what's happened in
the last twenty to thirty years
is these risk factors have been
supplanted worldwide with an additional
collection of risk factors that being
obesity and type 2 diabetes and what we
can see now from information in the
United States and now also confirmed in
the rest of the developed world and
being explored elsewhere is that these
two exposures obesity and type 2
diabetes actually go on to have now the
major attributable risk for developing
liver cancer obesity and type 2 diabetes
often times called diabesity actually
are the primary drivers of liver cancer
rate and arguably the drivers of the
major drivers of the increase in liver
cancer so why is it that obesity causes
these we know that actually obesity has
multiple potential outcomes that
clewd cancer obesity and cardiovascular
diseases but what's unclear is why do
some people go down the path of type 2
diabetes non-alcoholic steatohepatitis a
form of liver disease and ultimately
develop liver cancer whereas other
people can have an obesogenic ena type
with minimal morbid health outcomes or
others go down and develop
cardiovascular disease or others go down
and develop different forms of cancer
what is it that's driving these
different these different underlying
paths of disease progression
well my group has been interested in
using the role of inherited DNA
variation to better understand what
might be driving susceptibility to all
of these risk producing complex traits
common complex traits and what may be
driving the pathway down progression
that we just saw from obesity ultimately
to primary liver cancer
now the feasibility this is actually
well understood in the sense that we
know that phenotypes such as obesity and
type 2 diabetes have huge underlying
heritability arguably they have a
tremendous fraction of their total
variation in the population that's
driven by inherited genetic variation
even liver cancer as cancers go has a
very high heritability and you can
speculate if you need these other
precursor conditions that you may
actually even have among those than to
follow this path even higher
heritability we've done many countless
genome-wide Association studies to try
to identify the basis of obesity type 2
diabetes but to date there's been very
mixed success in having reproducible
findings and arguably this is because
complex phenotypes are not the product
of simple individual individual traits
or individual genes there is not a gene
for obesity there is not a gene for type
2 diabetes or aging for
cancer but in fact these complex
phenotypes manifest as products of
networks now in cancer we've known this
for a while again dragged kicking and
screaming perhaps into this point of
view by looking and seeing that we
couldn't explain cancer by looking at a
single individual gene but in fact we
need to look at combinations of genes to
understand the complexity of cancer so
what my group has been doing is now
using networks as our primary vehicle of
analysis and instead of looking for the
role of an individual gene we've been
using networks as an analytic framework
and embracing the emergence the
interaction between the individual
components to then explore the
susceptibility to the to the progressive
phenotypes as well as the outcome
phenotype of primary liver cancer so
we've done this by looking at a
combination of publicly available
genome-wide Association datasets three
public datasets for obesity four public
datasets for type 2 diabetes and a
historic data set for a man ascending or
carcinoma that we published on several
years ago interestingly what we have
found is as we analyze these complex
phenotypes obesity type 2 diabetes and
hepatocellular carcinoma at a network
level we recurring and simple patterns
begin to emerge by embracing the
complexity shown on this slide I
apologize for it being a little noisy is
a collection of pathways that we observe
to be significantly associated with
obesity type 2 diabetes and a Patou
cellular carcinoma and what is striking
about this is when we look within a
particular phenotype obesity being
represented here by BMI type-2 diabetes
type 2 diabetes diabetes being
represented by td2
HCC explaining liver cancer what we can
see it's unlike the standard genetic
analysis we're seeing with current
collections of lo site completely
reproducible across datasets within a
pipe and then more provocatively seeing
that several of these pathways appear to
underpin all three of these phenotypes
so we see unlike the traditional
genome-wide Association study high
reproducibility for our significant
effects by focusing on the biologic
pathway as opposed to the individual
underlying genes but more provocatively
we then see for instance that there may
be common underlying pathways that not
only drive susceptibility to the end
more bit morbid types but also that
drive the progression through the morbid
types so let's focus for a second what
do these pathways look like and one that
perhaps is a little surprising for for
all of these types for obesity type 2
diabetes and liver cancer axon guidance
now point out to you that pathways like
genes their names are not particularly
descriptive of what they do and I want
to focus in a little bit I realize this
is a largely unreadable lock diagram but
you can look at it on your leisure
afterwards after the presentation shown
on this diagram is is one of the
pathways that we use it's significant
across all three of the people within
and across all three phenotypes and
green indicates that they were genes
that we were being able to evaluate in
our jiwa studies significant indicates
that they were significant in the study
and red means that they the same
variants were significant across the
individual studies but let me blow this
up a little bit so let's focus in on a
particular area so let's focus in on
this area what we can see is that each
of these pathways is composed of modules
in this instance you can see this module
was the wint signaling pathway and
particular components that were
significant in that we can also see that
this pathway integrated another
module shown here at the top and this
module then contained both the map K
signaling pathway as well as regulation
of actin cytoskeleton so it becomes
interesting to see these pathways and if
we go back to the other table what one
could see is that in fact wind and map K
as individual pathways we're also
showing up so these pathways are
rediscovering common molecular
signatures it seemed to be driving all
three of these phenotypes
what's interesting given that
observation is if we take the individual
genes that constitute these pathways
interestingly 97 of 99 of them create a
master Network suggesting that there's a
common underlying connection a biologic
network that underpins susceptibility
progressing from obesity to type-2
diabetes to liver cancer now what is
this network and how did it come about
well I might argue that if we want to
better understand the origin of these
networks and better understand how these
phenotypes emerge in contemporary
populations that we need to embrace
evolutionary thinking this understanding
of biology there was all the way back to
one of the founders of modern
evolutionary thinking Theodore is
theodosius dobzhansky who argued way
back in the early 70s and others earlier
that if we want to understand things in
biology we need to look at them in the
context of evolution so I would argue
that the application of evolutionary
medicine thinking gives us new
perspectives for understanding the
phenomena that we're observing in things
such as type 2 diabetes - type 2
diabetes - liver cancer and also give us
a handle to interpret the results and
better understand why these systems
might exist the way they do so how might
we introduce a Lucian our thinking to
this particular problem
let's first start up is what has been
the primary driving force of human
evolution well arguably one could say
that the the thing that unites us as
humans in our evolutionary development
and adaptation it has been the expansion
of the human brain and it's through the
human brain that modern humans became
modern humans and shown here is just the
dramatic increase in the size of the
human brain during human evolution this
is quite striking when we look at the
context of the brain size and neuron
count and even though there are
organisms with quote-unquote larger
brains an African bush elephant for
instance has a much bigger total brain
in terms of its total law in terms of
its total size what we can see though is
that the global number of neurons that
are present in a human brain grossly
outstrip any of the other mammals and to
be honest any of our other primate
cousins so brain development has
unequivocally been one of the major
differentiators of humans in human
evolution so why is that important well
other than our adaptive adaptability and
our capacity to come conquer every niche
of the planet there's been a cost that's
come with this so having this big brain
huh is expensive having a big brain
requires us to feed that brain and we
actually know that the big brain
actually is a huge energy pig and that
arguably one of the things that has
facilitated the development of the human
brain was the virtuous cycle the
positive feedback loop that the more
humans became successful at hunting in
and group activity their sizes of their
brains were able to increase because
they had access to more energy but
their's
interesting additional permutation
that's a product of having a big brain
and that's that a big brain at least a
human size big brain not only requires
energy to feed it but also requires a
unique volume of lipids to construct it
so shown on this slide is just a cartoon
that shows the overall surface area of
individual type cells so you'll see a
typical human cell though there's
probably no such thing as a typical
human cell as a surface area of about
point zero zero two micrometers squared
however if you look at the size of the
neuron or you look at the surface area
of a neuron you can see that a neuron
has almost a hundred fold greater
surface area because of its dendrites
that extend out and then second off what
we can see is if you look at the most
extreme components of these that
underpin our larger nervous system
oligodendrocytes and it's a thousand to
ten thousand full larger so for us to
build our big brains we need both
calories to produce it but more perhaps
pragmatically or provocatively we also
need special collections of lipids in
order to build the brain and there's
been studies that have shown that and
you are limited deprived that in fact
look the deprivation can result in
microcephaly and results in actually
malformed brains so we needed to
actually if we were going to build our
big brains we needed to build the
cellular machinery the basic biologic
processes to support the development of
that big brain and in that then there
has been an evolution of how long chain
fatty acids are produced in humans and
what we can see is even compared to our
closest human relative chimps we can see
that in an animal
compared to the compared to our our our
great eight colleagues are great Ava
our family members we can see that our
lipids are not burned as an energy
source and then in fact when we consume
long-chain acids they're made into
longer chain acids as opposed to being
created or composed simply for the
purposes of being used as energy
consumption that we actually have
created specialized processes in our
lipid metabolism that allow us to meet
the needs of our developing big brains
shown on this slide is actually specific
mutations identified by the Rhea a tall
group where we can see specific mol
alterations mutations in the specific
processing of omega-3 and omega-6 fatty
acids have evolved and differentiate our
lipid metabolism from great AIDS and we
can see that the lipid metabolism
overall is fundamentally different in
our great ape cousins than in our our
own human family why is that significant
well one of the key places that this
lipid metabolism is you can see for
instance the elongation factors and
others where this metabolic processing
is taking place is in the liver and more
pragmatically we can see now if we look
at the liver now we can see that this
lipid metabolism is critically used in
terms of producing different long-chain
fatty acids and is critically important
in sugar and insulin management so now
we can see that the liver is central in
maintaining fat supplies and regulating
our insulin levels so our question that
was did the evolutionary chain
is that were necessary for us to produce
these long-chain fatty acids then result
in us actually increasing our list risk
to liver cancer has our big brains then
the evolutionary alterations necessary
to produce big brains and produce the
lipids necessary put us at risk for
liver cancer so to explore this we went
back to our pathway analysis focused on
the specific pathways that are
associated with lipid metabolism and in
fact saw and in all of these cases that
the lipid metabolism pathways all were
significantly over-represented in
individuals who develop liver cancer as
opposed to those who don't variation in
these very pathways appears to be
significantly different in those who
develop liver cancer versus those who
don't we can further reinforce this
finding by independent data by looking
at gene expression so in this instance
we can look at these same pathways by
comparing their variation in gene
expression both from this using
information from the gtex contortion of
human tissues looking at liver samples
from gtex and then comparing it to liver
samples associated with the cancer
genome atlas and look to see is
expression of these pathways different
in individuals with normal livers versat
individuals who have developed liver
cancer
so comparison i apologize for the small
size here we can see that if we look at
these five pathways we can see number
one that they are significantly
different in normal liver from two
individuals who go on to develop liver
cancer and interestingly what it
suggests is that these are
predisposition pathways that in fact
it's not a product of the cancer that's
changing these but the individuals who
have liver cancer go on to the
liver cancer have fundamentally
different gene transcription profiles in
several of these pathways and then in
fact the logic of these pathways the
lower panel of this slide is different
in individuals who go on to develop
liver cancer from normal individuals in
the general population so this suggests
that germline variation that we saw in
terms of variation that could be due to
evolutionary forces to develop big
brains are resulting in different lipid
metabolism in individuals who go on to
develop liver cancer from those who
don't so shown here is just focusing on
the specific genes and we can see when
we look at the liver cancer
susceptibility pathways to remind you of
the ones we saw that are different from
our evolutionary cousins the great apes
we can see that in this instance these
elongation factors and other key
variables associated with lipid
metabolism are critically different in
the liver cancer as opposed to
individuals who are not at risk at
delivering camp liver cancer so this is
just an interesting possibility if we
look at these particular pathways and
assemble them as we had done with
respect to our other investigation of
the overall liver cancer susceptibility
what we can see is that in fact these
pathways again form a master network and
the red dot that's unreadable I
apologize on this slide actually brings
in an interesting gene that may be of
significance that gene is is the 3
hydroxy 3-methyl uttaran MEK coenzyme
reductase gene there and that gene is
the targets used for treating
cardiovascular disease by statins so
perhaps this suggests that we could have
effects in liver cancer by using statin
treatments so again in this instance hgm
co reduct
is the primary target of stance that are
used to reduce cholesterol to manipulate
cholesterol in individuals with high
cholesterol interestingly though this
gene is at the hub of a variety of
critically important processes so it not
only manipulates your liver to your
lipid levels in your liver but it's been
observed that manipulation of this gene
has antiproliferative pro-apoptotic anti
invasive and cytostatic effects and
could be a master regulator of many
different underlying processes so this
suggests that statin treatment could be
an effective way to actually intervene
in liver cancer susceptibility so to
explore that a number of epidemiological
studies have been conducted and by
looking at individuals who are taking
statin use for other purposes and
monitor them in such things such as the
UK's clinical practice research datalink
in a paper published in 2015 we can see
that in fact individuals who are taking
statin do have a reduced risk of overall
developing liver cancer now again
there's many confounding possibilities
as to why this could be the case of
happy to answer questions related to
this but this is quite suggestive the
more definitive case though may be made
by examining clinical trials or specific
clinical trial where individuals with
liver cancer have been treated with
statins after resection and seeing the
recurrence rate and what we can see here
is from this particular Japanese study
that when statins were administered to
individuals
shortly after their their HCC surgery
that the risk of recurrence was reduced
by half so again striking but still
preliminary results in a relatively
small study so with that I'd like to
summarize saying that we think that
network analysis finds
and biologic processes within complex
traits that this systems approach allows
us to have insights that the
reductionist individual gene approaches
don't develop these Network analyses
identify common processes along disease
progression paths so we can not only
find the underlying etiologic basis
molecular basis of these traits but
perhaps indicate how things might move
forward or who is likely to progress
down increses increasingly severe
morbidity and ultimately have mortality
causing outcomes we can see that the
biologic processes are both expected
energy production and to be honest with
you somewhat surprising although in an
evolutionary context if you were not as
surprised that axon guidance might be
one of our underlying processes that's
driving susceptibility from obesity to
type-2 diabetes to liver cancer and that
there may have been evolutionary
trade-offs associated with the
development of the large human brain and
then that lastly that evolutionary
thinking provides novel hypothesis to
test and suggest risk reducing
interventions so with that I want to
thank the people who have actually
facilitated doing these studies my ASU
colleagues UConn Lou shantel Farrow
Madeleine Stark Jacob brill my former
colleagues at NCI and then the
individuals who donated the and
participated in the generation of the
original Korean case control study and
close then with happy to take questions
and as always our group is interested in
collaborators and partners who might be
interested in exploring any or all of
these individual phenomena so thank you
very much thank you dr. beautto for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started okay the
first question is why do networks of
snips show consistency across datasets
where individual snips don't thank you
very much is an interesting question and
I think one that maybe underpins the
whole route of this talk and that's the
recognition that genes work in
partnership with one another and that
the pattern of variation we see with
genes while individual variants produce
risk it's the combination the
interaction the higher-order terms of
these interactions that seem to be
whether it's crucial in in producing
risk that it's combinations of the snips
that are working together and that these
individual variants when observed in
isolation can vary from individual to
individual and from and from case and or
control but only when we look at the
combinations of them do we have
individuals who have everything that's
both necessary and sufficient to develop
cancer so they don't mitigate or cancel
the noise if we look at them in
combination thank you what does the gene
expression pathway analysis tell us that
these snip analysis doesn't so one of
the advantages that we have for the gene
expression analysis is the gene
expression analysis is complementary to
the DNA variation so what we're seeing
actually with the expression analysis is
what's actually happening in the tumors
by the tumors and in normal liver so the
gene expression analysis tells us what
the normal patterns would be within
these particular processes and then
allows us to contrast whether the
transcriptional differences reinforce
and support the information driven by
the DNA so you can argue that the
transcriptional information both is an
independent validation of what we saw
for the DNA variation
but it's also then represents an
additional insight because it's done at
a different level of analysis than what
one sees with respect to that that one
sees with respect to the DNA based
variation thank you for that your next
one is what do the pathways tell us
about mechanisms of progression so thank
you for that question it's actually I
think the pathways give us novel
biologic insight as to what actually is
driving the specific susceptibility to
the to the particular trace but then
clues as to why these traits may be
connected in progression so for instance
we can see that lipid metabolism
certainly would make sense as a driver
of obese phenotypes but the connection
of lipid metabolism to energy metabolism
in particular insulin like the
regulation of insulin as well as what we
could see when we looked at for instance
axon guidance and it's connection to
cell relevant proliferation as well as
connection to immune response may then
be critical drivers that having having
alterations in one component that makes
one susceptible to multiple different
complex outcomes
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question and it is could this
approach be applied in other common
complex diseases yeah thank you I think
that's a interesting and provocative way
to take this work forward is that is the
observation that in fact these pathway
driven approaches actually could give us
insight not just in this particularly
narrow area that we've looked at today
as proof of concept but in a variety of
other complex traits could be useful in
looking at phenotypes where we've found
literally again dozens to hundreds of
non reproducible single nucleotide
polymorphism snips
ah that are difficult to understand what
their patterns by integrating across
these networks we may get clues into
neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's disease or multiple
sclerosis or other autoimmune diseases
or cardiovascular disease so I think
that that this approach to looking at
the integrated phenotypes has been
barely examined to date and I think
could be very profitable in examining a
variety of different other common traits
that are huge public health challenges
well I would like to once again thank
dr. Bhutto for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
10th 2018 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon